[Music]
you
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive Monday January 15th it's the
halfway [ __ ] market a month of what
the hell have you done we already got a
[ __ ] day off happy Martin Luther King
Day to all the brothers out and the
[ __ ] struggle that's all I got
to tell you you know I'm saying you got
the day off the mailman's off the banks
closed we just had a [ __ ] vacation
two weeks ago that's what the problem
with this country is too many [ __ ]
vacations all of a sudden were brain
dead again for a death the day of who
gives a [ __ ]
uncle Joey here coming at you
Christopher Columbus day whatever the
[ __ ] it is Martin Luther King that three
for four days these were all the ones
that weren't Prince's safe in the stand
is just [ __ ] to kill Carrie Fisher and
her mother so that's the type of day
you're gonna have to that you don't say
look at that
maybe you're off maybe you're in [ __ ]
you gotta go to work play whatever it is
just a beautiful day to be alive grab
your balls what the mom oh you swingin
dick and you ain't backing down from
[ __ ] nobody understand me the rest of
you went out last night you're feeling a
little box you feeling like [ __ ] BJ
Penn today after that kick to the head
but what are you gonna do I didn't want
to see that [ __ ] fight either but
what are you gonna do Yair kicks like a
Mexican [ __ ] mule that guy could
Chuck the war with one [ __ ] leg you
know I'm saying anyway forget about all
that stuff it's what it was cracking up
in your life it's halfway during the
month that's it the holidays all the
hoopla's over you're realizing what the
[ __ ] am I gonna do of my life exactly
what you've been doing with your life
slinging dick get your notebook write
some goals do 22 push-ups nothing
happens on the [ __ ] couch [ __ ]
you can't make a move on the couch I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's a holiday my
best working days on the Lord's Day cuz
I don't give a [ __ ] jacket
tremendous I love this little model we
can get together and smoke a bowl and
golf for a week tonight we got the
podcast at 8 o'clock we got mushrooms we
got everything Wednesday we got this
show Thursday night Tempe Arizona The
Improv be there or be square [ __ ]
but forget about all that
Thursdays Thursday's today's Monday
that's all you need to worry about such
as the problem is how we're gonna do
Friday who gives a [ __ ]
it's Monday you gotta worry about we're
gonna suck your dick today whose lunch
box are you gonna [ __ ] eat out of
today that's the [ __ ] it keep writing it
okay
there you go blowing smoke to the SPD
throw smiles out then to get rid of all
these [ __ ] on a Monday you found
me but it was a great week and I had a
great time in Cleveland leavings a great
[ __ ] city man
Cleveland's my thigh the city you know I
love all those dark [ __ ] said he's
that's me
the rest of you little [ __ ] little
[ __ ] cities could suck my dick I'm down
with those blue-collar [ __ ] sense cuz
I'm as blue column as they come look at
that [ __ ] face I got hit with the
[ __ ] collar 18 times but at least I
know that going in
let's finish this container it's gonna
be a good day no matter how the [ __ ] do
you look at you don't say it because
sometimes a day is how you look at it
you might think this that just look at
it [ __ ] go into it with an open mind
don't be angry don't believe all your
emotion on the side and see what happens
trust me for years I [ __ ] up and I
going to a job mad and then you quit for
no vote for what what's the [ __ ] why cuz
you don't want to do with it's [ __ ]
resistance on your book listen have an
open mind
it's [ __ ] Monday you know I'm saying
what the [ __ ] I take a chance Columbus
did hear it from a different perspective
to see what happens to you see what your
opinion is of it
well until then we keep sparking cuz
that's what we doing that time to [ __ ]
chitter-chatter we in that time oh oh
this is you might wanna taste so sweet
who gives a [ __ ] up I came to get them
we came to get down we can't to see the
devil there ain't no other [ __ ] way
what what what do you want to live for
come to live to be like everybody else
and agree on everything I love
Portlandia oh my god what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you grab your balls live your
[ __ ] life take the [ __ ] [ __ ]
glasses off stop with the you like this
and you're like that was standing out
lines and going [ __ ] people's
birthdays that hold the [ __ ] 20 at a
restaurant huh [ __ ] worried
about everything this Title II who gives
a [ __ ] with Meryl Streep set all these
people walking around reciting Oh a
Meryl Streep who does a [ __ ] you know
I'm worried about I'm worried I'm up the
[ __ ] I got to say [ __ ] cuz that's the
only mom I got worried about street you
give you a loyal Tiffany's [ __ ]
people for no reason and um dick never
walked in your shoes understand me why
do you give me a loyal to you [ __ ]
idiots
once they walked in your shoes to be you
then you understand these people have
trainers and people cut their [ __ ]
sandwiches from and people who you're
great and all that [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] their mind is somewhere else
they have time to dwell on that [ __ ] we
don't what kill a bees we gotta be out
there every [ __ ] day bang and we're
not time to worry about what these
people worry about we don't let them out
there smoke a joint put your blinders on
who gives a [ __ ] the only mission that's
complete is but when you're after
everything else good suck dick I don't
give a [ __ ] about half this [ __ ] people
drop the made by are you [ __ ] crazy
but you gotta focus and ice it and
that's that I'm gonna smoke another ball
and I might take two steps I didn't get
out of here two steps for the real ain't
get out of here I'm saying oh yeah Luna
they didn't come I'm a girl I'm more
wrong though I don't really know you but
let me see their mama mopping up and
power just right cop we found a body
unbelievable tremendous it's a beautiful
day to be alive you got the world by the
balls and that's all that matters
the rest of it on here saying stupid I
love these people let's say stupid [ __ ]
on periscope and Twitter and stuff you
know you're actually telling me that
you're a [ __ ] Wallace [ __ ]
think about this isn't mine a computer
[ __ ] something saying little things
like oh my god I'm getting ahead in life
you're getting further and further away
from [ __ ] reality and one day you
don't be walking down the street and a
[ __ ] bricks gonna hit you in the
[ __ ] head
and when you're laying there thinking to
yourself why did this happen to me
you're gonna think about your [ __ ]
flaws and how you sit on a [ __ ]
computer and say stupid things to people
and think that you're witty in that you
have the world by the balls but
meanwhile you're just a scared little
[ __ ] [ __ ] that never had the balls to
take a chance on anything except typing
behind the computer saying things to
people it's [ __ ] amazes me where your
head is at it amazes me what type of a
person your mother raised your mother's
gotta be a worthless [ __ ] [ __ ] to
raise you to sit on the computer and say
little things to people especially if
you're Spanish I'm saying you're a
[ __ ] evil immigrant little [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you're just jealous of people
sitting there all day saying things it's
amazing where you're headed said you
know how I know cuz I was one of those
people I didn't have a computer I just
wished bad on people and you know what
happened to me I have nothing when you
sit there and wish bad on people you
know what happens to your eyes you know
your grocers zero that's why I keep
typing in three years you'll be in the
back room of a [ __ ] Asian power
sucking dick they'll be playing
blackjack
you know these are these people I think
they got ahead they sit there all day
especially if you're Spanish you should
be ashamed of yourself
red soup I smoke weed so I don't have
those evil thoughts now I'll sit there
wishing bad on people because the only
people when you're wishing bad on people
you hate the only people we hate on is
yourself so take that to the bank you
stupid [ __ ] beside that you're
all bad [ __ ] podcast tonight 8
o'clock don't even let me tell you who's
gonna be in I'm gonna have a good time
we got mushrooms
we got edibles we got reform most
importantly we got [ __ ] balls baby
it's gonna be a beautiful [ __ ]
day and you're ready stay black don't
let him kid you don't let him recite the
Meryl Streep deal
the [ __ ] smoke another one
ashamed of yourself but what do you ever
do
this is today's reality computer tough
guys amazing
have a great day uncle Joey loves you
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight get
ready to throw some heat [ __ ] cuz
we're on fire I got jujitsu I got a ton
of [ __ ] to tell you later